on the balance of probability are we
alone in the universe and second part to
that question if we're not Is it wise to
seek contact with those other sentient
life forms I think the balance of
probability is that we are not alone
um if we are alone in the universe then
that has interesting implications it
means that the origin of Life on our
planet was a supremely improbable event
so improbable that we're probably
wasting our time trying to work out how
it happened
um but I don't believe that and I I do
actually believe that we are one of many
um
uh life forms in the universe and I
would love to know what what the others
are like I mean I'd love to know how
unique we are I'd love to know why I
could make a few predictions I mean I
think I could predict that
um there's gonna it's gonna be darwinian
um it's going to be um is going to have
some kind of digital genetics
um there's not a business there's got to
be a very accurate genetic system where
you could make predictions of that of
that sort
um
Is it wise to uh well first of all
there's a very there's a big distinction
between life and sentient life
um uh intelligent life uh the um
intelligent life is a big step further
and so if there's there's probably a lot
more life around than there is
intelligent life around it's a big
barrier to get through there
um and intelligent life if we ever
encounter it but almost certainly
encounter it not physically we would
actually meet them
because the distances will be too great
um but
um we would most likely to meet them
through radio waves
um cities such for extra restroom
inheritance where they have actual
dishes pointing out looking for signs of
intelligent life
um
I don't think it's likely to be unwise
to respond to any such messages that we
find that we hear because
the distances again are so great and um
you wouldn't be able to have a
conversation we're in love with you even
even the
nearest stall
um is is
so far away that you could you could
only send a message and then you all be
dead before before you get with current
technological levels of development
wouldn't we be a little bit like the
Navajo sending a message and a bottle to
the two well it's been yeah but but if
you believe Einstein um then then there
is a limit to to
how fast information can can travel is
it limited to the speed of light yes
um and so
um the the I mean the two science
fiction books that I've read which
um come to grips with that that problem
is you you but um Fred Hiles
um
Ava Andromeda and uh Carl Sagan's
contact where
um both authors face up to the fact that
um the distances are too great for
Direct
control of humans for a direct
manipulation of humans we don't have to
fear that they actually come in flying
sauces and and run our lives how and you
can't run people's lives by radio unless
both books face this come to the same
conclusion
the the instructions are build a
computer
which will then
control Humanity both authors I don't
know whether the independent disorder of
it or whether one of them I forget which
of those books came first
um so the the Extraterrestrial
intelligence sends information
telling people to build a computer which
will do certain things
and the the original senders of the
information may be long dead
because it takes so long for the
information to get here
but once the information is here then
the computer
can work in
short-term time and come
um manipulate us and and in both cases
um that that's what very interesting
science fiction idea
and that's I think the only way we need
to be afraid we're not going to be
visited by people in flying sources that
I think is too improbable
thank you